wir sind derweil wieder zurück in Berlin
im bentlerblock also am zweiten
Dienstsitz des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums sie
sehen meine Damen und Herren eine totale
Einstellung so nennen wir das wenn sie
ganz viel sehen können und darauf können
sie unter anderem sehen dass da schon
diverse Gruppen von Rekruten Aufstellung
genommen haben 435 werden heute hier
geloben ihre Treue zur Bundesrepublik
aber auch zur Bundeswehr einer den ich
jetzt begrüßen kann steht hier oben und
nicht da unten auf dem Paradeplatz im
wendlerblock und das ist der
pressestaabsoffizier und Oberstleutnant
Uwe ziesak herzlich willkommen auch
ihnen vielen Dank und schönen guten
Abend ja heißer Tag heute hier in jeder
Hinsicht das kann man wirklich sagen
aber wir haben ja schon 16 Gelöbnisse
hier gehabt nicht nur auf dem Platz
sondern auch vor dem reiag und da hatten
wir alles gehabt heißes Wetter wir
hatten Sturm und Regen gehabt also es
war das komplette wetterprogramm
vorhanden heute mal 35° im Schatten das
war glaube ich so mal der letzte Stand
der Dinge aber ich habe gehört die
Rekruten haben gestern geübt und müssen
das jetzt alles aushalten können hier ja
die haben gestern natürlich schon
vorgeübt um die Örtlichkeit zu kennen um
sich mit den Örtlichkeiten hier mit den
Kommandos mit der ganzen Abfolge hier
vertraut zu machen und ich habe hier
heute Vormittag auch schon mit einigen
gesprochen die haben auch heute
Nachmittag eifrig getrunken weil doch
ein großer Flüssigkeitsverlust heute
hier mit Sicherheit eintreten wird in
der Tat Herr zisag das ist eines von
vielen öffentlichen von von feierlichen
Gelöbnissen welche Bedeutung haben diese
Gelöbnisse heute gerade und gerade an
diesem Tag heute für die Bundeswehr also
das Gelöbnis am 20 Juli ist ja mal vom
Bundesminister Rudolf Scharping
eingeführt worden
und ich hatte ja schon erwähnt zum 16
Male findet das heute statt natürlich
heute ein ganz besonderer Tag weil es
der 70 Jahrestag des Attentats auf
Adler jetzt findet es im Moment alle
zwei Jahre hier im bentlerblock statt
alle zwei Jahre vor dem Platz der
Republik warum dieser Rhythmus warum ist
man nicht vor dem Parlament geblieben es
ist wir haben hier eine Parlamentsarmee
so wird sie auch häufig genannt ja diese
Entscheidung lag natürlich bei den
Verantwortlichen beim
Bundestagspräsidenten bei der
bundesverteidigungsministerin und man
muss sagen gerade heute passt dies
löbnis hier wirklich hervorragend her
weil es eben der 70 jahrestag des
Attentatsversuch auf Adolf Hitler ist
also von daher kein schlechter Ort
sondern ein historischer Ort und wir
stehen ja auch direkt neben dem ehrenm
der Bundeswehr also steht im Reichstag
nichts nach zumal ja auch vier der
damaligen Verschwörer hier im
bentlerblock hingerichtet wurden noch in
der Nacht vom 20 auf den 21 Juli was
heute Nachmittag ja auch der
Bundespräsident in der Gedenkstunde der
Bundesregierung die hier im Ehrenhof
stattgefunden hat um 12r auch schon mal
noch mal betont hat und da ist ja dann
noch ein Kranz niedergelegt worden für
die für für die für alle Verschwörer
insgesamt
ähm wir werfen mal am besten einen Blick
auf das was hier gerade hinter uns
passiert und schauen auf die Rekruten
die hier Aufstellung genommen haben im
Moment wird gerade im Moment wird gerade
der gelöbnisspruch schon mal aufgezählt
es gibt zwar unterschiedliche Varianten
einmal für freiwilligere für die
freiwilligen
oder die Rekruten die freiwillig zur
Bundeswehr gekommen sind und für die
Zeitsoldaten ne sind ja beide freiwillig
zur bundesweh gekommen das E sind hier
nur freiwillig Wehrdienstleistende vor
einigen Jahren ist ja die whrficht
abgeschafft worden und das Gelöbnis ist
also nicht ganz so stark binden wie ein
Eid eingeführt das heißt die die sich
auch beruflich an die Bundeswehr binden
die schwören dann die geloben dann nicht
mehr sondern können Sie denn können Sie
das Gelöbnis
auswendig das Gelöbnis ja den dann sagen
sie noch mal wir gerade aus Versehen dar
drüber geredet vielleicht sollen wir es
einfach uns auch noch mal angucken was
welchen welche welches ja was die
Rekruten hier geloben ich gelobe der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland treu zu
dienen und das Recht und die Freiheit
des deutschen Volkes tapfer zu
verteidigen und daraus sehen wir dann
auch die Bedeutung oder wie sich auch
das selbst was das Selbstverständnis der
Bundeswehr auch wiederum weil h ganz
klar Bezug genommen wird eben auf die
Bundesrepublik auch auf das Grundgesetz
ja das war eine Diskussion die
stattgefunden hat vor 60 Jahren schon
lang her auch im Deutschen Bundestag wo
auch der Streit war überhaupt ein Eid
oder ein Gelöbnis noch abgelegt werden
sollte und da damals wurde mit
Parlamentsmehrheit festgelegt dass also
die wehrpflichichttigen ein Gelöbnis
ablegen sollten und mit diesem Gelöbnis
sollten Sie eben bekräftigen dass sie
eben zu der Verfassung zum Grundgesetz
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland hier
stehen und dass sie sich quasi dadurch
auch in die militärische Gemeinschaft
hier einfügen schauen wir noch auf das
was passiert hier vor uns direkt also
gerade Stille auf dem Paradeplatz des im
Bentler Block weil wir warten auf die
Ehrenformation und aus wem wird die
bestehen die besteht aus Teilen des
Wachbataillons und aus dem stabsmusikor
der Bundeswehr gut und die werden also
in dieser Minute eigentlich müssen sie
schon da sein hier einmarschieren jetzt
sehen wir gibt es ein entsprechendes
Kommando er erlutern s un ein bisschen
was passiert zum ein wir sehen einmal
den Kommandeur vom wachbataallon Herrn
oberstleutn Dr Axel Domen der jetzt hier
quasi den Einmarsch des seiner
ehenformation hier quasi abwartet und
ähm wenn wir das mer sehen wir sehen
hier auch quasi alle Uniformen vertreten
wir sehen hier luftwaffenuniform wir
sehen hier Marineuniform Streitkräfte
Basis Sanität also sind quasi alle fünf
Teilstreitkräfte hier der Bundeswehr
hier angetreten und da kommt jetzt die
Ehrenformation mit
[Musik]
Musik
geh
her
so damit ist die ehenformation
angetreten oberstlut zag was passiert
jetzt jetzt erfolgt gleich die Meldung
an die Bundesministerin der
[Musik]
Verteidigung und das bedeutet was das
bedeutet dass der Kommandeur der
Ministerin seine Meldung abgeben wird
und dass danach das Abschreiten der
frontstand durch die Ministerin durch
den Kommandeur vom wachbatillon und
durch den Generalinspekteur der
Bundeswehr
gelöbes auffstellung augeng gerade au
das
[Musik]
Gewehr Gewehr
ab gelöbtes
Aufstellung g ist
aufog
das
Gewehr Achtung resentiert das
wer zur Meldung Augen
rechts Frau Ministerin ich melde
gelöbnes Aufstellung Z feierlichen
gelöbens
[Musik]
angetreten
und zu den Klängen des preußischen
präsentiermarsches hat die
bundesverteidigungsministerin die
Ehrenformation aber auch die Reihen der
Rekruten abgeschritten das sind Rituale
oberstleuten an zag die sind quasi in
Stein gemeißelt oder da wird kein
Zentimeter unter
Interpretationsmöglichkeit ja die legen
seit Jahrzehnten fest und wie sie gerade
sagten in steingemeißelt das ist ein
festgelegter Ablauf der sich auch nicht
geändert hat jetzt gibt es den Gruß an
die rund 100 800 Gäste die sich jetzt
auch wieder von ihren Plätzen erhoben
haben und gleich wird
bundesverteidigungsministerin von der
Lin auch hier ihre Ansprache zu diesem
Gelöbnis an diesem ganz besonderen Tag
halten nämlich dem 70
Jahrestags 70 jahrestag des
gescheiterten Attentats auf Adolf
Hitler
ich begrüße sehr herzlich unsere
Ehrengäste Generalmajor aD Berthold
schenkgraf von Staufenberg und seine
verehrte Gattin Frau Mechthild
schenkgräfin von Staufenberg
stellvertretend für alle Angehörigen und
Nachkommen des Widerstandes sehr geehrte
Exzellenzen ich begrüße den
Vizepräsidenten des Deutschen Bundestag
es Herrn Johannes Singhammer für die
zahlreich anwesenden Damen und Herren
des Deutschen
Bundestages den werbeauftragten des
Deutschen Bundestages Herrn Helmut
Königshaus ich begrüße den evangelischen
Militärbischof Herrn Bischof Dr sigur
Ring für die anwesenden Vertreter der
Geistlichkeit und Militärseelsorge und
den Generalsekretär der Juden in
Deutschland Herrn Stefan
Kramer ich begrüße Frau Dr Monika von
Hassel meine Damen und Herren
Staatssekretäre ich begrüße
stellvertretend für die Anwesenden
Repräsentanten des Landes Berlin den
Senator für Justiz und Verbraucherschutz
Herrn Thomas Heilmann und den
Vizepräsidenten des Abgeordneten Hauses
von Berlin Herrn Andreas
Gram unseren Generalinspekteur Herrn
general Volker wi für alle militärischen
und zivilen Angehörigen des
Verteidigungs Ministeriums und des
nachgeordneten Bereichs für die
ehemaligen Angehörigen der Bundeswehr
Herrn General aD Leopold
schaluppa sehr geehrte
militärataches den Präsidenten des
Verbandes der Reservisten der deutschen
Bundeswehr Herrn Oberst ad Roderich
Kiesewetter den bundesvorsitzend des
deutschen Bundeswehrverbandes Herrn
Oberstleutnant Andrej
Wüstner den Bundes Vorsitzenden des
Verbandes der Beamten der deutschen
Bundeswehr Herrn Wolfram
kamm ich begrüße alle Anwesenden
Repräsentanten der interessenvertreten
tretungen ganz besonders die Rekrutinnen
und Rekruten und ihre Angehörigen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren Soldatinnen und
Soldaten sie werden heute
geloben der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
treu zu dienen und das Recht und die
Freiheit des deutschen Volkes tapfer zu
verteidigen dies ist nur ein kurzer Satz
aber ein Satz mit großem Gewicht ein
Satz der es in sich hat er bindet all
das zusammen wofür sie als Soldatinnen
und Soldaten der Bundeswehr
einstehen der Satz beschreibt was ihr
Land von ihnen wartet und er umfasst was
sie von ihrem Land erwarten und
einfordern
dürfen es geht um unseren freiheitlich
demokratischen Rechtsstaat ihm geloben
sie
Treue und es geht um die wesentlichen
Werte auf die wir unser Zusammenleben in
Deutschland Gründen Recht und
Freiheit das wird bes am 20 Juli
deutlich wir gedenken heute der
dramatischen Ereignisse vor genau 70
Jahren am 20 Juli
1944 haben die Angehörigen des
militärischen Widerstandes versucht die
nationalsozialistische
Schreckensherrschaft mit einem Attentat
auf Hitler zu beenden wir alle wissen
der Versuch scheiterte trotz aller
Bemühung er fand hier im Bendlerblock
sein tragisches
Ende Oberst Klaus schenkgf von
Staufenberg und seine Mitstreiter sind
eingestanden gegen die Auswüchse einer
menschenverachtenden Diktatur gegen
Willkür und Tyranei für das Recht und
die
Freiheit sie taten dies obwohl ihr Feind
übermächtig
erschien sie verkörpern damit
Tapferkeit in einem ganz besonderen
Maße Graf Staufenberg und die Männer und
Frauen um ihn haben Ihre persönliche
Situation angesichts des Kampfes gegen
die Diktatur
zurückgestellt sie haben
erkannt nicht der Blinde
Gehorsam nicht das
nichtsun nicht das
abwarten war das Gebot der Stunde
sondern das widerstehen das Handeln die
Tat für die Herrschaft des Rechts für
die
Unantastbarkeit der menschlichen Würde
und für die
Freiheit die Haltung von Graf
Staufenberg und all derer die das
Vorhaben unterstützten ist ein hohes Gut
das uns kostbar
ist diese Haltung findet sich in der
gelöbnisformel wieder die sie heute
ableegen werden denn wir alle müssen uns
jederzeit bewusst sein Recht und
Freiheit sind keine
Selbstverständlichkeit sondern sie sind
Werte die wir alle hüten und beschützen
müssen
sie Soldatinnen und Soldaten haben sich
freiwillig entschlossen dafür eine
besondere Verantwortung zu
übernehmen manch einer mag sich fragen
ob man als junger Mensch eher einen Teil
seiner Freiheit vergibt wenn man den
Dienst als Soldat
leistet meine Antwort heißt dass
Freiheit und Verantwortung
zusammengehören auch das ist ein
Vermächtnis des 20 Juli erst in der
Bindung durch
Verantwortung verwirklicht sich
Freiheit lassen Sie mich gerade am
heutigen Tage mit Blick auf aktuelle
Ereignisse einen Gedanken
anfügen die Werte die ich angesprochen
habe verbinden uns mit unseren engsten
Partnern und Verbündeten denen wir nach
den Tiefen der Diktatur und Krieg
unseren Weg in den Kreis der Demokratien
zu verdanken
haben gerade in schwierigen Zeiten wenn
Vertrauen erschüttert wurde sollten wir
uns im Klaren darüber sein dass wir vor
allem anderen zu einer Wertegemeinschaft
gehören dies ist ein hohes Gut das es zu
bewahren gilt und mit dem wir alle stets
verantwortungsvoll weits ich dtig und
mit Gradlinigkeit umgehen
sollten Soldatinnen und Soldaten ihr
Dienst in der Bundeswehr und ihre
Bereitschaft zur Verantwortung ist auch
uns dem Parlament
der Regierung und mir als
Verteidigungsministerin eine
Verpflichtung eine Verpflichtung genau
zu wägen wofür zu welchem Ziel und wie
wir sie beauftragen und
einsetzen wir werden dies nur tun zur
Verteidigung der Werte des Rechts und
der Freiheit auf denen unser Staat
gebaut
ist uns allen ist bewusst dass dies
nicht ohne Gefahren ist wir stehen hier
unmittelbar vor dem Ehrenmal für die
Soldaten der Bundeswehr die im Dienst
für unser Land gestorben
sind ein Dienst der nicht nur im
Auslandeinsatz sondern auch in der
Heimat oft genug mit Gefahren für Leib
und Leben verbunden
ist wir gedenken ihrer darum in Trauer
und in
Dankbarkeit Liebe Soldatinnen und
Soldaten liebe Gäste das Attentat des 20
juli traf die nationalsozialistische
Diktatur Biss ins Mark das zeigt die
blutrünstige Wut und Raserei der
Nationalsozialisten in den
darauffolgenden Monaten sie wollten
Rache nehmen um jeden Preis auch und
gerade an den Familien der
Widerstandskämpfer an den Frauen und an
den
Kindern sie sollten büßen für den Mut
ihrer Männer und
Väter ein Opfer dieser rasenden Rache
des regims wird heute zu unsprechen
Berthold Schenk Graf von
Staufenberg zwei Tage nach dem
Attentatsversuch erfuhr er als
Zehnjähriger vom Tod seines Vaters und
wurde
verschleppt wurde Opfer der sogenannten
Sippenhaft Sie verehrter Graf
Staufenberg haben einmal gesagt dass es
für die junge Generation die Unfreiheit
nie erlebt habe schwer sei sich in die
Angst vor Verläumdung und den
drakonischen Strafen aber auch in das
lähmende Gefühl der Rechtlosigkeit
hinein zu
versetzen umso mehr schätzen wir es dass
sie heute zu uns sprechen und ihre
Gedanken mit uns
teilen durch ihren beruflichen Lebensweg
schlagen Sie eine Brücke zum heutigen
Gelöbnis denn sie sprechen zu uns nicht
nur als ältester Sohn von Klaus schen
Graf von
Staufenberg sie sprechen zu uns auch als
Generalmajor aD der Bundeswehr als
Soldat aus Leidenschaft zu ihren
Kameradinnen und Kameraden ich freue
mich sehr dass sie heute bei uns
sind meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren ich möchte Ihnen allen danken vor
allem den Angehörigen dass sie heute an
diesem besonderen Tag hier sind sie
zeigen damit den Soldatinnen und
Soldaten ihre
Anerkennung Soldatinnen und Soldaten
ihnen wünsche ich für die Zukunft von
Herzen
soldatenglück alles Gute und bleiben sie
behütet soweit also die Ansprache der
bundesverteidigungsministerin es folgt
jetzt ein weiteres Musikstück viribus
unitis mit vereinten Kräften ist die
Übersetzung von Josef
Bach
[Musik]
viribus unitis mit vereinten Kräften von
josefbach und das waren durchaus heitere
und ja um nicht zu sagen leichte Klänge
an einem durchaus bedeutsamen Tag an
einem sehr bedeutsamen Tag hier am 70
jahrestag des gescheiterten Attentats
auf Adolf Hitler einer einer der damals
ums Leben kam im Anschluss an das
gescheiterte Attentat war Klaus schenkra
von Staufenberg jetzt spricht sein Sohn
sein ältester Sohn Berthold Maria
schenkgraf undon
Staufenberg Soldatinnen und Soldaten
meine jungen
Kameraden es ist mir eine Ehre zu Ihnen
sprechen zu dürfen heute wo sie den
ersten feierlichen Schritt in ihrer
soldatenlaufbahn tun indem sie
versprechen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland treu zu
dienen und das Recht und die Freiheit
des deutschen Volkes tapfer zu
verteidigen sie werden dieses
Versprechen gemeinsam abgeben aber
dennoch jeder und jede für
sich und muss ich über dessen Gewicht im
Klaren sein wir Gäste und nicht zuletzt
ihre Angehörigen H ja was sie
versprechen wir sind ihre
Zeugen eine Ehre ist mir besonders dass
ich als alter Soldat zu Ihnen sprechen
darf Frau Minister hat das gerade schon
erwähnt sie sind ja im Alter meiner
Enkel meine Dienstzeit ist vor fast 20
Jahren zu Ende gegangen und die
Bundeswehr in der sie heute dienen ist
eine ganz andere als die die ich erlebt
habe und der ich fast 40 Jahre gedient
habe und sie muss auch ganz anders sein
denn alles die außenpolitische Lage die
gesellschaftliche und die demografische
Lage und nicht zuletzt die Finanzen
haben sich seit damals seit meiner Zeit
dramatisch verändert und so mussten
aufbaust Struktur und Stärke der
Bundeswehr mehrmals an die neuen
Verhältnisse angepasst
werden dazu will ich und darf ich auch
gar nicht bei diesem Anlass etwas sagen
aber so viiel will ich doch sagen wenn
sie es mir allauben die Aussetzung der
Wehrpflicht schmerzt mich war sie doch
ein wesentlicher Teil unseres damaligen
berufsverständnises und für uns Garant
einer engen Verbindung von Streitkräften
und
Volk sie sind im Unterricht ausfüh
über Wesen und Sinn des Eides und des
feierlichen Gelöbnisses belehrt worden
und es wäre nicht angemessen wenn ich
dies hier noch einmal täte und
eigentlich versprechen sie ja gar nichts
Besonderes nichts was man nicht von
jedem unserer Mitbürger auch erwarten
dürfte von ihm nämlich darf man
eigentlich auch erwarten dass er sein
Vaterland diesen Begriff darf man ja
nach der Fußballweltmeisterschaft
hoffentlich auch noch benutzen dass
einin Vaterland und seine
gesellschaftliche Ordnung nicht nur für
seinen persönlichen Vorteil ausnutzt
sondern das in seinen Kräften Stehende
für es tut dass er für das Recht die
Grundrechte und die geschriebenen
Gesetze immer und überall ganz
persönlich Eintritt und schließlich die
Freiheit unseres Volkes unsere
freiheitliche gesellschaftliche Ordnung
gegen Bedrohung von außen aber auch von
innen verteidigt
der Unterschied zu dem wozu sie sich
jetzt feierlich und rechtswirksam
verpflichten liegt in dem Wort tapfer
tapfer heißt die eigene und ganz
natürliche Furcht überwinden letzten
Endes bis zum Einsatz des eigenen Lebens
das Ehrenmal
hier für die im Dienst gestorbenen
Angehörigen der Bundeswehr ist Zeuge
dafür dass Kameraden im Einsatz ihr
Leben eingesetzt und verloren haben und
und ich will auch mit uns allen hier in
Trauer ihre gedenken persönlich auch in
Demut weil mir selbst ein solcher
Einsatz nicht abgefordert worden ist
aber auch ganz banal im täglichen Leben
kann es vorkommen dass sie in der
Ausübung ihrer Pflicht als Staatsbürger
und Soldat Tapferkeit beweisen müssen
auch unter in kaufnahme von persönlichen
Nachteilen
nicht zufällig sind sie am 70 Jahrestag
des Attentats auf atlos Hitler hier
angetreten und ihre Erwartung dass ich
darüber spreche will ich wenn auch
wiedderstrebend
nachkommt ich will nicht über den
Widerstand gegen den Nationalsozialismus
sprechen ihm habe ich als damals
zehnjähriger nicht angehört und von ihm
habe ich nichts gewusst als Angehöriger
einer Famil jedoch die die Folgen zu
tragen hatte und natürlich später auch
in den über 38 Jahren als Soldat der
Bundeswehr da musste ich für mich selbst
klären was das tun meines Vaters und
seiner Gefährten für mich bedeutet und
ich will versuchen Ihnen nahzbringen was
der militärische Widerstand gegen Hitler
für den heutigen Soldaten bedeuten
kann
die die damals ihr Leben wagten und zum
größten Teil dann auch verloren die in
Kenntnis der Natur des Naziregimes die
Verfolgung ihrer Familien in Kauf nahmen
die haben selbst ihre Aussicht auf
Erfolg gering
eingeschätzt was sie Antrieb war nicht
der so ungewisse realpolitische Vorteil
sondern die moralische Empörung darüber
dass Hitler und seine kompane dem
deutschen Volk in dessen Namen zu
handeln sie Vorgaben seine Ehre
gestohlen
hatten indem sie das Recht also genau
das was sie tapfer zu verteidigen
versprechen mit Füßen traten und dies
sowohl gegenüber den eigenen Landsleuten
als auch und das schlimmer noch
gegenüber den
Angehörigen anderer
Staaten dass sie sich nahmen was sie
wollten dass die Verträge brachen die
sie eben erst geschlossen hatten und am
schlimmsten dass sie diejenigen die sie
als rassisch oder geistig minderwertig
betrachteten als nicht lebenswert
bezeichneten und fabrikmäßig
umbrachten die Verschwörer erhoben sich
um das Recht und sie sagten die Majestät
des Rechts und die Freiheit des
deutschen Volkes von seiner
Unterdrückung
wiederherzustellen und sie taten es
weitgehend allein
denn im Gegensatz zu 1989 in
Ostdeutschland erhob sich ihr Volk 1944
eben nicht gegen das Regime des Unrechts
im Gegenteil immer noch vertraute es mit
Mehrheit seinem Führer und glaubte wenn
auch zunehmend zweifelnd an seinen
endzieg das wussten die Verschwörer ihn
war bewusst dass sie gegen die Mehrheit
des Volkes und somit oberflächlich
gesehen eigentlich und demokratisch
handelten worum ging es aber Ihnen als
sie sich vor 60 Jahren gegen die
Unfreiheit vor über 60 Jahren über die
Unfreiheit und Rechtlosigkeit auflehnten
und denen ihr Heldentum gelegentlich
auch heute noch bestritten wird es ging
ihnen um die Ehre es ging ihnen zur
förders um die nationale Ehre um das
moralische Ansehen unseres Volkes vor
Gott und der Welt und versuchen Sie
nicht dieses zu retten
so sahen sie auch ihre persönliche Ehre
verspielt es ging ihnen auch um ihre
soldatenehre sie sahen sie befleckt
durch das was auch in ihrem Namen
geschah nicht zuletzt durch das
militärische und auch moralisch Versagen
der hohen militärischen Führung die mehr
aus Schwäche als aus Überzeugung ihr
berufseetos verraten hatte und allzu
viele aber bei weitem nicht die Mehrheit
ihre Untergebenen mit sich gezogen hatte
Ehre welch ein altmodischer Begriff
manche einer denkt da gleich an
Ehrenhändel an Duelle auf sbel oder
Pistolen oder ähnliche leppische
Übertreibungen schlimmer war natürlich
dass die Nazis das Wort Ehre durch
schamlosen übermäßigen Gebrauch für alle
Zeit entwertet zu haben schienen man
denke nur an das Motto der SS unsere
Ehre heißt Treue also bedingungsloser
Gehorsam statt Verteidigung des Rechts
aber heißt das dass es Ehre heute nicht
mehr gibt dass für uns einzeln oder als
Volk Ehre kein handlungsmaßstab mehr ist
was bedeutet denn Ehre für uns hier für
Sie für mich für uns
alle vielleicht mache ich es mir ein
bisschen einfach aber für mich bedeutet
es dass wir uns in den Spiegel ansehen
können ohne uns schämen zu müssen uns
schämen für das was wir etwa getan haben
aber viel schlimmer und wäufiger für das
was wir nicht getan haben dass wir etwa
Unrecht geduldet haben dass wir
weggeschaut haben dass wir gekniffen
haben dass wir feige gewesen sind und
sagen Sie mir nicht dass es dafür
heutzutage keinle andersergibt würden
wir wegschauen und kleifen als
allgemeinen verhaltensmaßstab
akzeptieren würden wir uns nicht anders
verhalten als der kleine Mann auf der
Straße und es waren leider meistens die
Männer
vor 70
Jahren das hat dem deutschen Volk damals
seine Ehre gekostet und es kann sie
durchaus auchoch heute wieder
kosten was aber soll dieser
verhaltensmaßstab
sein für mich ist es das Gewissen und da
muss ich Ihnen ein persönliches
Geständnis machen es gibt für mich kein
Gewissen ohne religiöse Überzeugung und
Grundeinstellung
über Jahrhunderte war in Europa und
angefachtet und angefochten dass das vom
Rittertum überkommene soldatische ETOS
ein religiöses war ein christliches
sogar dass den Soldaten nur dies davor
bewahrt hat in der Unmenschlichkeit der
Kriegswirklichkeit selbst zum Unmenschen
zu werden für mich gibt es keinen
Zweifel dass genau dies für diejenigen
die sich dazu entschlossen ein
entscheidender Beweggrund für ihren
Widerstand gegen Hitler war
andererseits hat der Verlust der
religiösen Bindung in weiten Teilen
unseres Volkes nach demem ja schon
erwähnt vor 100 Jahren begonnenen Ersten
Weltkrieg nicht
unwesentlich zu einem Verlust der
moralischen Orientierung beigetragen und
dazu dass sich so viele so
unverständlich bedingungslos politischen
Verbrechern und ihren dieszeitigen
heilelslehren verschrieben haben und
auch die schrecklichsten Befehle ohne
großes Zögern ausgeführt
haben der 20 Juli ist der Tag des
Gedenkens an die am widerstanden
Beteiligten der zivilen wie vor allem
hier der
Soldaten dies waren übrigens Bost Teil
dieser Wehrmacht ohne die der Zweite
Weltkrieg auch mit seinen Verbrechen
nicht möglich gewesen wäre aber eben
auch nicht der Widerstand dagegen wie er
im 20 Juli kulminiert ist die die
Soldaten die sich gegen Hitler
verschworen haben waren es die die Ehre
der Armee ja unseres Volkes gerettet
haben und ich zweifle ob ohne sie eine
Bundeswehr hätte geschaffen werden
können wie wir sie kennen und auf die
wir stolz sind deshalb gedenken wir
ihrer heute gedenken heißt aber dass wir
uns nicht nur an den Anlass als Datum in
der Geschichte erinnern sondern dass wir
für uns selbst bedenken was damit von
uns ganz persöhnlich gefordert
ist wir sie heute wie wir vor fast 60
Jahren haben das Glück und müssen
dankbar dafür sein dass wir in unserem
Dienst nicht vor solche existenziellen
Gewissenskonflikte gestellt werden
unsere Verfassung und unsere von uns
gewählten Politiker sind Garant dafür
dass sie keine Aufträge erhalten und
ausführen müssen die gegen unser und das
internationale Recht verstoßen steht
dies im Zweifel werden unsere Gerichte
Klarheit schaffen es ist
selbverständlich dass mit der
parlamentarischen Kontrolle oder
political control wird es auch genannt
dass mit der dieser Kontrolle der
Streitkräfte auch die Verantwortung
unserer politischen Führung für die
Einsätze der Bundeswehr und auch für die
Durchführbarkeit der Einsätze
einhergeht
lassen mich hier ein paar persönliche
Worte anschließen ich stehe vor Ihnen
hier nicht ohne ein Gefühl der Bewegung
vor mehr als einem halben Jahrhundert
war ich selbst junger Soldat und vor
fast genau 58 Jahren habe ich als einer
von 18 offizieranwerärtern den ersten am
2 me 1956 eingetretenen Rekruten des
Panzer auflehungslehrbataillons in
Bremen Groh meinen soldateneid geleistet
es war keineier iche Angelegenheit wie
heute wir waren im kleinen
Dienstanzug außerd dem damaligen
Arbeitsanzug hatten wir überhaupt noch
gar nichts anders und im
kompanieunterrichtsraum sprach dann der
Kompaniechef die Eidesformel vor und wir
haben sie nachgesprochen übrigens ganz
bewusst und ohne Ausnahme mit der
Bekräftigung so war mir Gott
helfe es gab keine Musik und so wie so
keine truppenfahner die erst 9 Jahre
später sie können sich denken dass wir
über diese äußere Form oder viel mehr
den Mangel daran gemurrt haben und der
nächste al Appell es gab noch keine
wehrpflichten und auch deshalb kein
feierliches gelöbtes hatte dann auch die
gebührende feierliche Form verstein sie
mir dass ich das hier eingefüt habe für
sie ist der heutige Tag der erste
wichtige in ihrer soldatenlaufbahn es
wird einige Zeit dauern bis Sie alle
Ausbildungsabschnitte von den
möglicherweise nicht alle mit im
Soldatenleben stehen bis sie die
abgeschlossen haben dafür wünsche ich
Ihnen zunächst Erfolg und
erfreuge irgendwann kommt aber für
einige von ihnen der
Tag an dem Ihnen Verantwortung
übertragen wird dies mag schwer auf
ihren Schultern lasten unter den
Umständen der heutigen Einsätze
wahrscheinlich schwerer als seiner Zeit
auf unserern dafür wünsche ich Ihnen von
Herzen Glück sie haben einen Beruf erw
indem ich eine ganze lange Dienstzeit
glücklich war und das nicht nur dank
einer nicht unbefriegenden
Laufbahn das Wort Beruf kommt von
Berufung und das ist etwas anderes als
Job Berufung ist etwas fürs ganze Leben
ich habe nach meinem Eintritt in den
Ruhestand vor fast 20 Jahren nicht
aufgehört mich als Soldat zu fühlen
anders als wir vom dr orj werden wohl
die meisten von ihnen nicht bis zum
Pensionsalter dienen sondern nach
einigen Jahren wieder in das Zivilleben
zurückkehren ich hoffe dass sie dann mit
dem Ende ihrer milizärit nicht auch ihre
jetzige Berufung vergessen das fmer das
Ethos und die moralischen grundätze auf
die sich ihr Soldat sein gegründet hat
auch weiterhin bei ihnen Glück
Gültigkeit haben dass sie bildlich
gesprochen dann den grauen oder blauen
Rock nicht nur in den Schrank
hängen und nicht etwa in die
Altkleidersammlung geben vergessen Sie
nicht sie sind hier heute weil unser
Staat also wir alle sie in einem
strengen Verfahren unter vielen
Bewerbern ausgewählt hat das Fremdwort
dafür heißt Elite und nun erwartet er
aber auch wieder wir alle dass sie dem
gerecht werden und ihm und uns treu und
pflichtbewusst dienen so wie sie es
gleich versprechen immer noch auch in
unserer oft seinerseits als
Spaßgesellschaft andererseits als
rücksichtslose Individualisten bezeiten
Welt sehen unsere Mitbürger ihre
Soldaten auch falls Sie sie nicht lieben
noch weitgehend als etwas Besonderes
sogar als etwas von dem manche gerne
etwas hätten das ist aber kein Grund zur
Arroganz sondern nur
Verpflichtung noch meine allerbesten
Wünsche für ihre Zukunft noch einmal und
nun stehen sie bitte äußerlich stramm
aber innerlich locker und aten Sie tief
durch dann ist das auch alles viel
leichter auszuhalten vielen
Dank und das ist der Beifall für berthol
Maria schenkg von Staufenberg ältester
Sohn von Klaus schenkra von Staufenberg
einem der Hitler Täter die hier vor 70
Jahren im Bendler Block hingerichtet
wurden in der Nacht vom 20 auf den 21
Juli mit seiner gelöbnisansprache er ist
ja heute hier der Ehrengast und das war
mal erfrischend pragmatisch was sie hier
gehört haben das hätte auch sehr viel
pathetischer ausfallen können stehen sie
äußerlich stramm aber innerlich locker
das ist glaube ich ein Satz den wir uns
schön merken können für den restlichen
Tag es geht weiter mit Musik es kommt
des Großen Kurfürsten reitermarsch von
kunograf von
[Musik]
des Großen Kurfürsten reitermarsch und
jetzt wird's ernst Oberst leutn ziesack
wie geht's weiter jetzt in den nächsten
Minuten jetzt äh wird die fahenabordnung
vortreten wir haben hier nur eine
Truppenfahne vom Wachbataillon
eigentlich hat jeder Truppenteil eine
Truppenfahne dann müssten wir hier sechs
truppenfahen vortreten lassen das würde
den Rahmen etwas springen und wir haben
gerade gehört in der Ansprache von
Berthold KF von schraubenberg dass er
als er vereinigt waren ist gar keine
truppenfahen da gewesen ist keine Musik
kann nichts also eine recht einfache
Zeremonie und er beneidet sie ja so ein
bisschen die Rekruten heute dass sie so
eine große Kulisse hier haben für ihr
feierliches gelö es ist trotzdem eine
Ausnahme denn das kriegt ja trotzdem
nicht jeder in dieser Form ne ich glaub
die allermeisten werden auch weiterhin
ohne Musik und ohne truppenfah doch ne
nee mit Musik und und Truppen ST ja
durchwg
ja also ich kenne das noch be bei meinem
feierlichen Gelöbnis wurde die Musik vom
Kassettenrekorder abgespielt ja ist
schon etwas länger her
heute würde das auf MP3 vorlegen und
jetzt passiert das was sie eben
angesprochen haben die marschieren jetzt
zur Mitte die
drei der fahenträger mit zwei fahen
begegleitoffizieren vom Wachbataillon
treten
vor und es werden aber nicht alle
Rekruten dann jetzt natürlich sondern es
werden einzelne Abordnungen aus den
jeweiligen Truppenteilen die hier
vertreten sinden die stellvertreten für
die nach vorne gehen und dann vorne an
die truppenfah anfassen und
leisten
Gewehr
ab göbnes Aufstellung
R Abordnung der
Rekruten
vortreten
[Musik]
so da sehen wir jeweils zwei vom her von
der Luftwaffe und von der Marine von der
Marine genau die rein das können wir
hier ohne dass wir der Zeremonie einen
Abbruch tun die reinen haben sich ein
klein wenig gelichtet weil der eine und
andere Rekrut dennoch aus diesen Reihen
raustreten musste es ist ja doch etwas
anstrengend über die lange Strecke hier
zu stehen und da haben einige dann doch
kleinere Probleme mit dem Kreislauf
bekommen sind dann in Sicherheit
nach hinten gebracht worden und können
sich ein klein wenig
erholen
[Musik]
Gelöbnis Aufstellung zum feierlichen
Gelöbnis
das Gewehr
über Achtung präsentiert das
er zur Truppenfahne
Augen
rechts
Zeitsoldaten sprechen sie mir zu
feierlichen gelöbbis nach ich schwöre
ich schwöre
werdienstleistende sprechen sie mir zum
feierlichen gelübnis nach ich gelobe ich
gelobe sprechen sie mir alle nach der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland treu zu
dienen treu zu dienen und das Recht und
das Recht und die Freiheit des deutschen
Volkes und die Freiheit des deutschen
Volkes tapfer zu verteidigen tapfer zu
verteidigen augeng gerade
aus
[Musik]
du
V l uns
allees
schen
der
eil wel
und
sind
für
[Musik]
das Gewehr
über Gewehr
ab
gelübtes
Aufstellung ich stelle fest dass sie
geschworen und gelobt haben der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland treu zu
dienen und bereit sind das Recht und die
Freiheit des deutschen Volkes tapfer zu
verteidigen
so jetzt gibt es einen Programmpunkt der
heißt Bekräftigung des
treuebekenntnisses mit Handschlag durch
den Ehrengast die Bundesministerin der
Verteidigung ursola vonderlein den
Generalinspekteur der Bundeswehr general
Volker wia und den Kommandeur des
Wachbataillons Oberstleutnant
axeldomen und anschließend werden die
regkrutenabordnung und die
fahenabordnung wieder zurück
in ihre jeweiligen reintreten welche
Bedeutung hat das was jetzt hier
passiert damit wird noch mal das
Gelöbnis bzw ein J haben wir auch ihren
Eid heute hier abgelegt ähm bekräftigt
und die Ministerin und der
Generalinspekteur Wechsel noch mal ein
paar paar Worte hier mit den
Rekruten so woher kommen sie was sind
sie von Beruf was hat Sie bewogen hier
vielleicht zur Bundeswehr zu gehen das
sind so die üblichen Dinge die da vorne
dann hier ablaufen abgeschlossen ist das
Gelöbnis damit allerdings noch nicht
nein es geht noch weiter es geht noch
weiter die rekrutenabordnung und die
fahenabordnung werden zurücktreten
danach werden wir noch die europahimde
hören und dann kommt da der Ausmarsch
der
ehenformation dann noch mal die Meldung
an die Ministerin dass das Gelöbnis
durchgeführt wurde und dann ist dann
Schluss und wir stellen fest wir werden
da ganz schön an die Schau ranrücken mit
dieser Veranstaltung hier heute die
ursprünglich so ca jetzt in diesen
Minuten schon beendet sein sollte das
verzögert sich ein klein wenig aber es
ist auch äh nicht weiter verwunderlich
es gab ähm eine außergewöhnliche ähm
Ansprache eines Ehrengastes der nicht
irgendwer ist sondern der älteste Sohn
des eines der Attentäter auf Hitler hier
vor 70 Jahr es ist vor allem auch ein
besonderer Tag nach wie vor auch für die
Bundeswehr für die Bundeswehr auf alle
Fälle und zwar steht der 20 Juli in der
Traditionslinie der Bundeswehr neben den
preusischen Reformern und der Geschichte
der bundesweh
selber so jetzt wie angekündigt werden
die Abordnung wieder zurück zu ihren ja
wie nennt man das Formation zu ihren
Formation schreiten so zunächst die
Rekruten und wir haben gehört
dass sowohl Zeitsoldaten als auch
ähm also die ja dann auch
diesen geschworen haben auf
sich entsprechend zu verhalten als auch
[Musik]
whrdienstleistende gelöbes
Aufstellung das Gewehr
achtung restiert das
er
zur Truppenfahne Augen
rechts Fahne
[Musik]
Marsch
wir sind
im und
augeng gerade
aus
[Musik]
das Gewehr
zum ausmach der Truppenfahne Augen
rechts
rechts hier
information
[Musik]
und während die ihrenformation den parad
Platz hier im wendlerblock verlässt
können wir noch ein wenig reden über das
was heute alles so stattgefunden hat und
was darüber hinaus es noch an
Diskussionen ja durchaus geben wird in
der Bundeswehr heute hat der
Bundespräsident gesprochen beim bei der
Gedenkstunde der Bundesregierung er hat
im letzten Jahr auch beim Gelöbnis
gesprochen und damals schon vor ja
gesagt deutschland dürfe sich nicht aus
der Verantwortung stehen
zunächst sein politische Mittel zu
verwenden aber wenn es sein müsste dann
müssten eben auch
militärische Mittel eingesetzt werden
wenn es irgendwo auf der Welt zu
Ungerechtigkeit kommt denn wen und und
Unterdrückung denn wenn man sich nicht
einmische dann sei das sicher auch ein
Fehler das sind Sätze die ja in den
Folgemonaten mehrfach wiederholt hat die
dann auch für viele Diskussionen gesorgt
haben wie weit wird dies im Moment auch
in der Bundeswehr diskutiert oberstleutn
ziesak also eher Wener aber diese Sätze
hat ja nicht nur der Bundespräsident
gesagt der Bundesaußenminister hat sich
ja ähnlich geäußert auf der Münch
Sicherheitskonferenz die
Verteidigungsministerin hat sich ähnlich
geäußert und ich gehe auch mal davon aus
dass vor allen auch der Bundespräsident
darauf aus ist eine
sicherheitspolitische Diskussion
anzustoßen ist ja schon oftmals passiert
Minister de hat das schon mal versucht
hat nicht so funktioniert hier und dass
man über die zukünftige Rolle
Deutschlands auch im breiteren Teilen
der Bevölkerung über die zukünf Rolle
diskutiert ja in diesen in diesen
Sekunden
endet das Gelöbnis denn jetzt wir noch
mal Meldung gemacht bei der
bundesverteidigungsministerin wie wir
sehen das Ende des
feierlich da lächelt sie und dankt und
das bedeutet dass die Rekruten die hier
tpfer ausgehart habenfalls die die bis
zum Schluss noch stehen bleiben konnen
wie gesagt es hat einige einige doch
Probleme mit dem Kreislauf und sind dann
in hier von Sanitätern dann auch
genommen worden das heißt aber um das
noch mal aufzunehmen was sie eben gesagt
haben eines der Leitbilder der
Bundeswehr ist ja das des Staatsbürgers
in Uniform resultiert auch aus dem was
es vor 70 Jahren geschehen ist unter
anderem das heißt es gibt derzeit keine
lebendige Diskussion in der Bundeswehr
über Auslandseinsätze oder mehr
Auslandseinsätze als bisher also
innerhalb der Bundeswehr gibt's da aus
dem Kameradenkreis keine Diskussion in
der Beziehung es wird eher diskutiert
über die gesamte Neuausrichtung der
Bundeswehr auch die Innenstruktur wir
sind ja einem riesigen Umwälzungsprozess
also da wird vornehmlich drüber
diskutiert und das wäre ein Feld über
dass wir einen ganzen Abend gesondert
noch mal reden konnten vielen Dank
oberstleutn zisag dass Sie bei uns
gewesen sind und dass dieses Gelöbnis ja
heute mitkmentiert haben Ihnen meine
Damen und Herren sagen wir schon mal
einen guten Abend verweisen auf das
dokodrama um 20:15 Uhr das sich noch mal
mit den Attentätern des 20 Juli
beschäftigt und mit den Bildern hier vom
Paradeplatz im bendbar Block geben wir
zurück nach
Boner